[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ce nouveau journal
nouvelle semaine d'information locale
sur tv 60,18 bienvenue dans cette
édition tout de suite les titres de ce
lundi 25 novembre après trois mois le
grenelle des violences conjugales a pris
fin aujourd'hui en cette journée
mondiale pour l'élimination des
violences à l'égard des femmes la
réaction aux annonces gouvernementales
du collectif nous tout 78 l'occasion
aussi de revenir sur la marche organisée
samedi à paris le hisse porte fait des
adeptes avec plus de 7 millions de
joueurs réguliers en france une journée
dédiée se dérouler ce lundi au campus
des mureaux conférences démonstrations
et pratique le département des yvelines
ayant mené des classes de 5e et puis
elle a pour vocation de créer un réseau
solide entre les start up et entreprises
du territoire la french tech paris
saclay faisait sa première soirée en fin
de semaine dernière c'était en clôture
et du sky business day au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
on présentera tout à l'heure aussi la
quatrième conférence du club climat
énergie demain et puis en cours et ce
qu'il faut retenir de l'actualité
sportive du week-end à suivre dans ce
journal
138 féminicide commis depuis le début de
l'année ce 25 novembre c'est la journée
mondiale pour l'élimination de la
violence à l'égard des femmes et date
retenue par le gouvernement pour
clôturer son grenelle des violences
conjugales qui a duré trois mois bonsoir
anne geno vous êtes l'une des
cofondatrices du collectif nous tout 78
on va parler avec vous bien sûr de cette
marche qui a été organisée samedi à
paris et qui a rassemblé plus de 50000
personnes dans les rues de la capitale
mais d'abord le bilan la réaction aussi
aux annonces du gouvernement qui ont
marqué la fin de ce grenelle le premier
ministre edouard philippe adressé une
cinquantaine d'années aujourd'hui parmi
les principales à retenir l'ouverture de
centres de prise en charge pour les
conjoints violents l'état va cofinancer
à hauteur de 50% deux sites dans chaque
région est la suspension de l'autorité
parentale des père violent la notion
d'emprise aussi qui sera inscrite dans
les codes civil et pénal offrir la
possibilité aux médecins de déroger au
secret médical en cas de danger devant
enfin former les enseignants sur
l'égalité entre les filles et les
garçons c'est une série d'annoncés qui
seront soumises aux députés à
l'assemblée nationale et qui s'ajoute en
fait à celle faite au début de ce
grenelle notamment des places
d'hébergement d'urgence la création de
procureurs référent beaucoup d'annoncés
en somme
anne geno est ce que tout de même ce
n'est pas satisfaisant nous toutes
appelé ce soir à paris à un
rassemblement une action éclair ça veut
dire que vous n'êtes pas satisfait de
ces annonces non il ya une grande
déception de la part de nous tout est de
toutes les associations féministes car
ces mesures vont dans le bon sens bien
sûr mais
déjà elles sont incomplètes et puis
aucun budget supplémentaire n'a été
prévu pour les mettre en oeuvre
alors qu'on sait bien que pour agir il
faut il faut de l'argent au ministre a
parlé de là en tout cas de consacrer un
milliard d'euros à l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes et c'est ce sont
360 millions qui seront consacrés
directement contre les violences faites
aux femmes c'est ce qu'ils font c'est ce
qui était déjà le budget de l'année
dernière malgré ça il ya eu 138
féminicide ce qui veut dire que si on
garde le même budget on aura le même
nombre de meurtres l'année prochaine
donc c'est totalement insuffisant et
quand il parle d'un milliard en fait
c'est pluriannuel déjà c'est pas pour
une année et en plus ça concerne toutes
sortes de d'inégalités aussi bien en
france qu'à l'étranger ont dédié aux
violences faites aux femmes qu ans comme
c'est le cas par exemple dans un pays
voisin comme l'espagne
oui l'espagne a vraiment une volonté
très forte de mettre fin aux violences
faites aux femmes
ça a été efficace parce que des moyens
ont été mis en oeuvre justement
débloquer un milliard d'euros ce chiffre
de 1 milliard vient de n'est pas un
chiffre sorti du chapeau comme ça c'est
un chiffre qui a été émis par le haut
conseil à l'égalité ça correspond à des
mesures concrètes chiffrés et
c'est vraiment ce qui serait nécessaire
pour agir réellement et vous disais des
mesures incomplète qu'est-ce que vous
demandiez en plus justement à laquelle
on est très attachés c'est la formation
dans les écoles on aurait aimé qu'il y
ait une politique exactement comme pour
la sécurité routière pour former très
jeune des enfants à la non-violence de
former les enseignants il faut aussi
former les jeunes on aimerait mettre en
place un brevet de la non violence pour
apprendre à aux garçons ce que c'est que
le consentement pour apprendre aux
filles qu'elles ont le droit de dire non
quand même pas envie de dire oui et
c'est très jeune qu'il faut apprendre
ces choses là aux enfants parce que une
fois adulte c'est quelquefois trop tard
c'est dire que si on dresse le bilan on
à la fin de ce grenelle des violences
conjugales
de votre point de vue en tout cas il n'a
pas servi à grand chose
non puisque aucun budget supplémentaire
n'a été débloqué et ce qui veut dire
qu'aucune action supplémentaire ne sera
fait voler quelques mesures pénales ou
autres juridictions sont intéressantes
bien sûr mais sans argent on s'y baigne
des associations ne pourront pas faire
grand chose de plus dans les
commissariats les gens sont débordés on
parle de 80 personnes supplémentaires
pour mieux accueillir les gens dans un
pays comme la france qui à presque 100
départements ça fait même pas une
personne par département c'est
insuffisant
et voilà on est très déçu au niveau du
budget parce qu'on voit bien qu'il n'ya
pas une vraie volonté de changer les
choses
deux jours avant ce grenelle justement
nous toutes appelé à une grande
mobilisation à paris le résultat plus de
50000 personnes qui ont défilé dans les
rues de la capitale contre les violences
conjugales il ya déjà peut-être sur le
chiffre oui attention yanis
l'indépendant qui a qui a chiffré à 50
et le nombre de personnes à paris oui
nous on pense plutôt de 5000 personnes +
50 millions province donc un total de 58
personnes est vraiment c'était
impressionnant ce défilé qui s'est
étalée sur plusieurs kilos mobilisation
ah oui les vend énormément personnes qui
étaient là de tout âge de faim toutes
sortes de gens et enfin des gens sont
venus crier leur colère et leur
tristesse et
malheureusement le gouvernement ne les a
pas entendus il ne faut pas écouter et
ça nous sommes très déçus
et pourquoi l'organisait juste en cette
grande mobilisation deux jours avant la
fin de ce grenelle pourquoi quels
étaient les objectifs de la date était
choisie avant que le grenelle soit
annoncée ça correspondait en fait à la
journée d'aujourd'hui contre les
violences faites aux femmes
c'est pour ça que c'est le même timing
mais donc cette mobilisation c'était
dans le but d'interpeller le
gouvernement justement pour faire savoir
que de très nombreuses personnes sont
concernées et sens et souhaite qu'il y
ait une politique de lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes une journée
qui faisait suite à la grande
mobilisation déjà d'il ya un an qui
s'est également déroulée dans les rues
de la capitale
dans le cortège présence massive de du
collectif nous tout 78 oui de très
nombreuses personnes sont venues dans
qu'au niveau du collectif nous avions
organisé des départs groupés
depuis on se vide les yvelines donc au
total 90 personnes s'étaient inscrites
pour pour ce départ et ç'a permis à des
gens de se connaître et
les deux marchés ensemble et c'était
vraiment une très bonne ambiance et et
puis bon quand on a organisé plusieurs
actions mobilisation ça nous a permis de
rencontrer des gens aussi qui ne sont
pas forcément venu à la manifestation
mais qui nous ont dit qu'ils étaient
sympathisants de la cause et c'était
l'occasion d'échanger à ce sujet et rien
que la préparation de la réunion est de
faire de la manifestation c'était
vraiment des gens intéressants de parce
que ça permet de rencontrer des gens en
restant un peu moins d'une minute le
comité divine on précise qu'il a été
créé suite à la grande mobilisation dit
alain en voilà il ya des rencontres qui
sont nés de cette mobilisation
son objectif pour le comité c'est
d'organiser des actions d des animations
au niveau local de sa wii alors comme le
gouvernement ne fait pas ce qu'il
devrait faire nous tout est déterminé à
prendre le relais à intervenir dans les
entreprises dans les écoles dans l'est
dans la rue partout dans les familles
pour justement sensibiliser les gens
pour les motiver à à refuser la fatalité
et faire évoluer les mentalités
on retrouve toute l'actualité toutes les
informations sur le comité local de nous
tout sur la page facebook un qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran merci à
genoa d'être avec assurance et aggravent
également le message est passé merci
beaucoup d'être venu en plateau et je
rappelle que vous êtes l'une des
cofondatrices de nous tout 78 merci et
concernant les violences faites aux
femmes vous retrouverez mercredi un
reportage au sein du portail de
signalement de ces violences ce portail
a été inauguré un pourra-t-elle il ya un
an au commissariat de guyancourt et dans
l'actualité locale de ce lundi une
journée a dédié aux is porte au campus
des mureaux trois classes de cinquièmes
rencontres et des streamer aider
youtuber spécialisés qui en ont fait
leur métier est l'occasion d'aborder
avec eux les contraintes de cette
profession il est difficile de se faire
une place mathilde admis pour le
reportage apprendra streamé mais aussi
comment jouer en réseau c'est avec
trixie ena pool youtuber et streamer que
les élèves de 5e vont s'entraîner sur la
plateforme twitch quel deal et tous les
jours avec leurs communautés de 50000 et
770 milles abonnés moi je vais animer un
atelier streaming donc je l'apprends nos
enfants tout ce qui est
gérer son image tout ça je vais leur
apprendre les bons côtés comme les
mauvais côtés parce qu'il faut aussi pas
se voiler la face c'est un beau milieu
mais il ya aussi des choses des mises en
garde en fait tout simplement comme dans
tout bon boulot on va dire surtout quand
on est seul et qu'on doit se diriger
seul et à le reste ça va être de la
nutrition lis portes de la pratique on
va vraiment les mettre en condition
aujourd'hui en fait des ateliers qui ont
conquis les collégiens qui rêvent à
présent de devenir streamer
professionnels et puis j'ai 8 ans jouent
aux jeux vidéo
donc ça me dérange pas d'être le
matériel c'est tout ce qui fait que je
veux ça coûte trop cher et la journée
cédant entre mes mains
malgré tout le métier de streamer reste
compliquée avec des obligations comme
faire du sport avoir une bonne hygiène
de vie voire des professionnels de santé
c'est ce que ce professeur de ps
souhaite que ses élèves retiennent un
sport c'est pas forcément très physique
il ya des compétitions donc ça peut
s'appeler comme ça après y'a pas tous
les jeux ne sont pas uniquement à si on
a le jeu du fond où justement on est
debout d'affaires des mouvements des
spots en musique etc et à just dance
aussi qui existent voilà il y aussi des
mouvements
il n'y a pas que ça mais après c'est
vrai que le côté physique ou un manque
un peu aux élèves et sajoo impex sur la
sédentarité en pleine expansion avec
tous les jours de nouveaux jeux comme
fortnight league of legends ou encore
fit pas ce métier du futur séduit de
plus en plus de jeunes qui se lancent
sur le dur marché de youtube la dernière
séance du conseil départemental des
yvelines s'est tenue vendredi dernier à
versailles parmi les mesures adoptées
par les élus un financement exceptionnel
pouvant aller jusqu'à 1,5 million
d'euros pour reconstruire le chapiteau
de chanteloup les vignes ou encore le
pass malin étendu désormais au
département des hauts-de-seine fait rare
l'assemblée a également retiré une
délibération de son ordre du jour
elle visait à accorder un financement de
17 millions d'euros pour le tram 13 et
l'échangeur de satory un financement non
obligatoire pour la société du grand
paris dans le cadre du contrat de plan
etat-région explications au micro
d'aurélie ronces l'état aujourd'hui
quitte à l'incapacité
et sa part nous a volés je pèse mes mots
en disant ça nous a volés par un
amendement scélérat à l'ensemble des
collectivités d'île de france
l'un des départements et la ville de
paris 75 millions d'euros pour financer
la part du contrat de plan etat-région
la part de l'état qui n'avait pas payé
donc nous disons à l'état si vous nous
prenez de l'argent en plus pour financer
votre part de ce contrat de plan on voit
pas pourquoi vous ne financent eux riez
pas dans ce cas là notre part dans un
communiqué publié aujourd'hui les sept
départements d'île de france et la ville
de paris demandent l'abandon dans les
plus brefs délais de cette mesure
du côté de guyancourt un événement
demain soir à la batterie une conférence
débat sur le réchauffement climatique en
présence de jean jouzel le climatologue
co-prix nobel de la paix en 2007 viendra
échanger avec le public et présenter le
pacte finances climat qu'il a imaginé
avec un essai les pierre larrouturou à
début de conférence
20h30 à la batterie toujours concernant
le climat est toujours à à guyancourt
l'autoconsommation et le consom'acteur
pour une meilleure transition
énergétique le thème de la quatrième
conférence du club climat énergie c'est
demain mardi dans l'après midi sur le
campus de bouygues challenger le site de
bouygues challenger et pour en parler et
xavier de la porte
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes l'animateur du
club climat énergie de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines déjà pour le
présenter si une association qui
s'adresse avant tout aux entreprises
alors majoritairement aux entreprises
effectivement au travail avec les
pouvoirs publics et les ports privés
l'idée du club steve énergie c'est de
pouvoir collaborer des réflexions au qui
viennent à la fois du monde économique
et des entreprises
mais par rapport à également aux besoins
du secteur public notamment à terme
d'aménagement du ou des territoires en
faveur de la transition énergétique et
pourquoi c'est important d'avoir ce club
pour donner aussi la possibilité aux
entreprises d'échanger sur la transition
énergétique pourquoi c'est un sujet
voilà qui est intéressant et important
pour les entreprises cette transition
énergétique salaires des sujets parmi
les plus importants on parle de
transition numérique
on pourrait parler aujourd'hui de
transition énergétique également parce
qu'il ya des sujets qui sont majeurs
tant du point de vue de l'innovation
aujourd'hui de la performance
énergétique et notamment donc par
rapport à la facture par beaucoup
d'énergie on sait tous très bien on
n'entend jamais parler que le prix
l'énergie augmentent et aujourd'hui
essaient de répondre de proposer des
solutions vis-à-vis alors par les
entreprises pour l'ensemble du secteur
économique ou pour le secteur public et
indirectement pour les habitants c'est
un certain effort qu'on doit tous faire
aujourd'hui qui est nécessaire de la
même manière un coup droit il faudra
faire sur la pédagogie enjeu important
est forcément aussi beaucoup de
réglementation qui n'est pas toujours
aisé de comprendre ces six as et
accompagner ces entreprises
alors la loi change régulièrement pour
pour exemple la dernière loi énergie
climat vient d'être votée elle a tout
juste 10 jours dans lesquelles il ya
différents thèmes dont notamment à thème
sur votre consommation qui est
relativement compliqué parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de d'impact réglementaire et
franchement pour expliquer tout ça je
dirais à l'ensemble dès rejets
radioactifs mais également des acteurs
économiques si quelque chose conquis
sous pas de manière facile
de l'autre côté avec nos partenaires on
passe déjà du temps pour bien lire des
textes les comprendre je peux vous dire
qu'elle est batterie d'avocats qui ont
aussi le rôle d' essayer d'expliquer ça
c'est un exercice c'est un vrai exercice
et une on s'y attache et à partir de ça
dont la cde déduire les projets qui
seront nécessaires ou en tout cas qu'on
pourra lancer et qui composent ce club
climat énergie de 50 en ligne est ce que
c'est uniquement les entreprises du
territoire ou aussi des taureaux des
territoires vraiment environnants alors
aujourd'hui c'est le club thème énergie
de 51,9 ils se sont très majoritairement
évidemment les entreprises 51 divine
on ne se limite pas vous vous prenez
quelques grandes entreprises qui sont
plutôt nationale elles sont également
membres du club climat énergie ce sont
par exemple des énergéticiens
on a besoin d'eux et on a besoin de
leurs compétences dont qu'ils apportent
leur savoir-faire pour le territoire des
villes mais c'est vrai qu'on est un peu
plus orienté sur le cinquantenaire sans
pour autant nous interdire et on l'a
déjà fait d'échanger par exemple avec
versailles grand parc où avec la
communauté de paris saclay non si on en
vient la conférence de demain je
rappelle le thème l'autoconsommation et
le consom'acteur pour une meilleure
transition énergétique
un mot sur le thème déjà de quoi
sera-t-il question est pourquoi centré
sur ce thème demain or aujourd'hui
lorsqu'on parle d'énergie renouvelable
se pose toujours la question avec de la
performance faut-il aujourd'hui par
exemple prenons des panneaux
photovoltaïques
nous produisons de l'énergie grâce aux
panneaux photovoltaïques qu'est-ce qu'on
en fait
et l'une des questions aujourd'hui c'est
de se dire est ce que finalement la
revend ce qui était quand même habituel
et aujourd'hui vu que les prix des
panneaux photovoltaïques ont baissé ça
devient plus pertinent de l'auto
consommera seco de l'auto consommer
c'est à dire nombreux et qu'ils
électricité pour une propre système pour
vos installations pourquoi pas demain
pour recharger le propre véhicule
électrique donc c'est un sujet qui est
aujourd'hui extrêmement qui devient
mature et qui devient très performant et
sur lesquels on a souhaité concentrer
une conférence demain sur 707 nda est en
tout cas avec une volonté d'être
pédagogique d'expliquer ce que c'est et
puis lens l2 présenter quels sont les
tenants et aboutissants un sujet de plus
en plus actuel on l'a compris le
programme de la conférence demain qui
débutera à 13h30 alors le programme
commence à 13h30 on aura en fait deux
tables rondes avec deux experts une
première table ronde plutôt on parlera
on expliquera des enjeux la technologie
est ce qu est l autoconsommation et
l'autoproduction à votre consommation
font penser autoproduction et une
deuxième table ronde où là et ça c'est
une vraie valeur comme en avant au
niveau du club climat énergie qui sera
un peu plus orientés vers le
consommateur le consom'acteur c'est là
que c'est le consommateur qui agit en
faveur de la transition énergétique
on ne peut pas faire aujourd'hui de
transition énergétique si on n'implique
pas l'utilisateur final et si on ne les
explique pas ce qui peut faire derrière
et c'est une conférence qui
malheureusement pour laquelle
malheureusement les inscriptions sont
déjà closes mais vous pouvez retrouver
en tout cas toutes les informations sur
le club climat énergie sur son site
internet qui s'affiche et aussi les
prochains événements organisés par
l'association merci à xavier de la porte
d'être face et sur ce plateau animateurs
et du club climat énergie de saint
quentin en yvelines
c'était leur premier événement à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines justement
l'association french tech paris saclay a
organisé une soirée jeudi dernier
c'était en clôture du sky been business
day qui se tenait le même jour au
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines moment de
rencontre entre les start up mais aussi
avec les autres entreprises du
territoire pour créer des synergies
nicolas landry c'est l'esprit start-up
se retrouver autour d'une partie de baby
foot ou de tennis de table se détendre
tout en faisant des rencontres pour le
business
le principe de l'association french tech
paris saclay dans une démarche ou aux
caisses et ambiance sympa mais on
échangeait carte de visite
on va en trouver quelque chose quelques
points communs cette association veut
rassembler les quelques 400 start up du
territoire du plateau de saclay jusqu'à
versailles satory en passant par saint
quentin en yvelines
à paris ça qu'il ya une particularité et
c'est une constitution deux tiers de ce
qu'on appelle le startup deep tech donc
qui portent des sujets en rupture
souvent issus des milieux académiques ou
la recherche publique lancée le 4
juillet 2019 french tech paris saclay
cherche à attirer des adhérents et des
futurs partenaires c'est un label qui
est reconnue désormais même à
l'international et donc c'est important
pour nous de faire partie de cette
communauté de ceux de tout ce réseau de
professionnels
la clé du développement économique c'est
la rapidité et l'agilité une start up
est par définition très agile par contre
elle est souvent un peu isolé et donc il
lui faut du réseau pour toucher les
grands groupes
il faut pouvoir être plus visibles et
avoir une association telle que la
french tech et avec des parents qu'ils
soient des grands industriels du cac 40
c'est un excellent moyen
après le plateau de saclay le vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines la
prochaine soirée sera organisée à
versailles
[Musique]
comme tous les week-ends du sport au
programme aussi dans les yvelines on va
voir l'essentiel un des résultats
sportifs avec mitel et demi d'euro bonds
soir face à grégory de la rédaction de
tv 78 le journaliste sport de cette
rédaction on commence par du rugby
michael la fédérale 2 on n'était pas
loin de la victoire pour plaisir
pourtant plaisir avait mis tous les
ingrédients pour réussir à emporter à la
victoire mais une deuxième mi temps de
folie n'a pas suffi lors de la 9e
journée de fédérale 2 après un premier
acte dominé par chartres 17 à 10 des
rugbymans plaisir oies se sont ressaisis
en deuxième période devant leur public
qu'ils arrivent à inscrire deux essais
dont un à deux minutes de la fin du
match pour passer devant 24 à 17
mais en quelques minutes leurs espoirs
de victoire s'effondre chartres marque
un essai de pénalité puis arrive à
inscrire une pénalité quelques secondes
plus tard ce qu'en finale le 27 à 24
pour les visiteurs des faits de jeu
effectivement des coups de pieds qu'on
envoie directement en touche des choses
non maîtrisée des quelques touches aussi
con conquête qu'on n'a pas de trois
ballons qui nous manque énormément
forcément ça 24 parties ont loupé deux
pénalités pour gagner effectivement
bombe a eu de la m ouais ça s'est joué à
deux trois faits de jeu sur la fin
et malheureusement ça tourne ça tourne
contre nous on quand il vous fait
plaisir se retrouve désormais à la 10e
place du classement de fédérale 2 avec
seulement deux victoires au compteur
l'équipe se retrouve en danger pour la
suite de la saison
forcément on va on va on va pas mettre
la charrue avant les boeufs et voilà on
va être humble encore une fois on a
travaillé que militer mais voilà on va
tout faire pour se maintenir encore une
fois cette année pour se ressaisir et
continuer à croire au maintien les
plaisirs aux âges auront sur le terrain
d'orléans le 8 décembre prochain les
derniers à du championnat grégory du
handball pour poursuivre michael le
championnat de nationale 2 féminine
après une mauvaise série de deux
défaites consécutives montigny le
bretonneux se reprend les i monteyne se
sont imposés sur le terrain de patronage
laïque et granville sur le score de 23 à
la meilleure buteuse côté montigny le
bretonneux se prénomme delgado des
gracques a avec 7 buts en 13 tirs avec
cette victoire la smb handball pointe à
la 5e place à deux petits points de la
première place détenue par tall carantec
on termine par du football ce n'est pas
un résultat mais un match important
à venir un agenda le tirage au sort du
8e tour de la coupe de france de
football a eu lieu la semaine dernière
et versailles qualifié après sa victoire
3 2 face à sainte marie à la réunion a
été épargné le dernier représentant
évinois se déplacera chez un club de
nationale 3 vivre ce tour est le dernier
avant l'entrée en lice des clubs de
ligue 1 en 32e de finale là une dernière
versailles s'est arrêté à ce huitième
tour de la compétition contre lens on va
croiser les doigts pourquoi pas pour une
belle affiche contre un club de ligue 1
avec nos amis de versailles merci
michael pour ce tour d'horizon bien plus
de résultats des reportages et des
annonces aussi d'événements sportifs
à suivre dans votre émission sept huit
sports le 7-8 forcée dans quelques
minutes sur tv 78 pages culturelles à
présent dans ce journal avec d'abord cet
événement qui se déroulait à elancourt
le salon du livre revenait à la
commanderie dimanche pour une troisième
édition ça se passait donc à la
commanderie the lady est organisé par
l'association des amis du passé
d'elancourt environ 70 auteurs étaient
présents avec également et des éditeurs
un événement qui a un thème prédominant
chaque année l'interview est au micro de
patrick jacques de dixmude j'avance
choisi
comme thème aventure nature et
découvertes et donc là comme d'habitude
une soixante dix huit heures sachant que
le président d'honneur monsieur
franceschi qui a eu le goncourt des
nouvelles et hier soir il ya eu un
partenariat aussi avec le ciné set
puisqu'il ya eu deux documentaires qui
ont été présentés qui était formidable
sur la boudeuse et sur les aborigènes de
l'île de la paume côte
ce week-end il y avait également une
nouvelle édition de faites de l'histoire
cette année les archives départementales
se sont associés aux musées de la ville
de saint quentin en yvelines pour
s'intéresser au lieu de vie marylène
iapichino et patrick jacques de dixmude
à reconstituer la cité des dents de scie
de trappes avec une maquette colorée une
fresque sur l'histoire des yvelines pour
cette journée spéciale fêtes de
l'histoire les archives départementales
ont organisé plusieurs ateliers dans la
découverte de leur activité cette année
nous avons dédié la journée au
territoire à son lieu d'habitat c'était
l'occasion de découvrir les ressources
dont nous disposons sur ce sujet et puis
aussi de permettre au public de
découvrir la ville de saint quentin sur
lesquels nous sommes implantés au
travers de parcours de visite de jeu de
piste et de maquettes qui sont
disponibles chez nous pour cette édition
les archives se sont associés aux musées
de la ville de saint quentin en yvelines
ils ont proposé des visites de quartier
et un stand avec notamment des jeux pour
enfants les deux entités se complètent
pour faire découvrir l'histoire locale
au public par exemple au musée ya risque
et cartes postales ou visites et aux
archives ya la maquette du
du quartier en question donc on peut
vraiment travailler en complémentarité
l'un avec l'autre thématique centrale le
territoire et les lieux d'habitat une
façon pour les visiteurs de redécouvrir
leur ville
je suis pas venu chercher quelque chose
en particulier celui voir comment les
gens travaillaient aussi de voir quels
matériaux il utilisait pour faire leurs
recherches
parce que moi c'est quelque chose qui
m'a toujours beaucoup intéressé
l'histoire d'un lieu l'histoire d'une
ville l'histoire des gens aussi
et s'il ya bien un endroit on peut voir
ça c'est aux archives dernières photos
avant de partir avec des cartes postales
anciennes pour garder un souvenir de
cette journée est du passé pour refermer
ce journal souvenez vous elle a été
installée en octobre à guyancourt
l'oeuvre le rocher en granit avec bras
lièvre et ben a été inauguré ce week end
cette sculpture de 20 tonnes et le choix
d'une dizaine de commanditaires
habitants du quartier du pont du rotois
re une nouvelle fois patrick jacques de
dixmude accompagné de mélanie poker un
rocher comme dernière pierre comme un
symbole du réaménagement du pont du
rotois re le rocher au granit avec bras
livrer ben a été choisi par une dizaine
de commanditaires il ya eu tout le
processus au travers notamment de la
fondation de france qui était présente à
est représenté ce matin et puis surtout
ce qui était important c'est d'associer
les habitants du quartier
au travers de ce dispositif les nouveaux
commanditaires quand on travaille
énormément actuellement justement sur
l'art urbain et sur la rénovation et
d'entretien de 7 heures cet art urbain
parce que je pense que c'est tout à fait
de l'image d'innovation de création de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et il faut
garder cette entité là une oeuvre de 20
tonnes qui conclut un processus de trois
ans elle s'intègre au coeur de 5
hectares de terrains où se mêlent 500
logements une clinique une résidence
hôtelière et des équipements publics
c'est aussi encouragés par le ministère
de la culture dans le cas d'une d'une
démarche s'appelle un immeuble une
oeuvre ou qui encouragent les opérateurs
les promoteurs les aménageurs a inséré
dollars dans les nouvelles constructions
ou dans l'aménagement de nouveaux
quartiers de penser par les artistes
daniel de vars et grégory gicquel
l'oeuvre est doté d'un bon pour
accueillir les passants à la fin de ce
journal merci de l'avoir suivi belle
soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]